let's let's go into the
um the
EO the EDI part okay the x pattern it's
it's different okay uh but all the all
my techniques are different they just
appear not to be because I
think uh you're not well to be honest
you're not looking closely enough you're
still using your Federation eyes to see
this
um but there's different things these
are different and this EO is very
different um because it's based on fight
experience so uh mid-range grappling is
a lot about controlling the extremities
of the body um which is important
because weapons are involved in real
fighting so um for me in law
enforcement uh it's always very hard as
I train people that do modern martial
arts
uh because they want body control and
it's all like yeah but now he can draw a
weapon and so they learn really fast
when we allow the weapon in in play that
you need to control the limbs and
so mid-range grappling you are going to
play off in a dilemma uh between control
of the center and control of the limbs
and the way that this isn't oppositional
is through your internals so when I
touch a limb I am still touching the
center uh that's very very important but
you're still playing off how do I get
these arm isolations which is what we
call them today uh and the way you get
them is whenever you attack someone's uh
balance the arms will the arms will
always reach out from AC away from the
body exposing them to arm isolations
or whenever and so or larger whenever
you attack the core the spine line the
people always extend their arms out and
that's what generates the arm isolation
so a real simple one if he's down on the
ground and I have
Mount and um he could be all kind of
hidden here and not letting the these
this arm stuff but when you start
punching at his face then every time
you're getting there the arms get
further and further out as you're doing
this and now you have your arm
isolations that you can attack okay um
and that is what in
essence I the EO is doing so on the
first one you get his balance going you
see um he might he might have his arms
all all Clos you see and I can't get
those techniques I can't get that but I
moved his body and then the arm came the
elbow came away from his torso and
came away from his torso and that's
always what makes the arm isolation
possible so if we look on the on the
mount
one when his elbows are tight to his
torso you just can't get leverage on
that but as it moves away then then it's
easy to do so that is what you're doing
in uh eel he has his tight elbows and
when you go that's when the elbow came
away
and now that arm is isolatable okay the
difference in II in II Jiu-Jitsu schools
is when you touch the arm you're not
just going to try to get the arm you
touch the arm to keep controlling the
the center of his body okay
okay so that's what we're
doing um so let's get to here we don't I
don't care how you do this let's make it
a micro drill I'm only going to work on
part of the technique so we can even
start here okay and what we're going to
look at is
thei so we know our starting
point
here start here and then I'm going to
give you the ending
point that elbow his elbow is under my
center line the wui line okay that's the
ending point
and then I'll give you some
parameters my elbow articulation angle
remains in katata DOI on both arms
so this angle which is
discoverable by the natural extension of
your arms here you don't hyperextend
them don't bend them where are they here
that's where katot
is that's where my arm so don't
hyperextend this one I'm in that
articulation and I keep it all the way
through the
technique for
okay we're going to work on those things
we got our beginning we got our ending
and we have one parameter to work don't
have these arms go in and out what does
in and out look
like here
here this kind of stuff no that's not it
okay all right here we go
wait
okay this way
please and keep going
okay more
parameters um we'll review the one about
the yin Yong grid okay so the
let's say this is the elbow
hand
the grabbed hand brings it in the inward
spiral to the wui line and neither Yong
nor Yin line the midline that's where
the wrist hand is going to pick
up what the driving position who's the
team leader here that's the te so here
it
goes over
meets picks up
continues over to the left
Yar that will
bring the
elbow onto the wuji
line where it ends on that line at the
bottom we know that we also know that
the inward
spiral is a matter of how the wrist and
the elbow are related to each other so
they don't go like this there's there's
no spiraling around yes my arm moves
from right to left but the elbow
relation to the wrist didn't change the
wrist on the inward Spiral goes in and
the elbow goes
out on the other side you have the
outward spiral and I don't go like this
because again there's no arm movement
here the wrist goes out and the elbow
comes in that's what happens it's just
hard to see because inside of that
spiral I actually
moved
okay but I'm not just going like
this then we also know from previous
videos that my elbows never go outside
the Yang line so when you're doing this
your elbows can't go outside that
shoulder line never outside the outer we
know all that
okay um some more parameters you have to
make sure your hands and your arms your
elbows are doing
this then we also
know that my spirals don't move from my
shoulders they don't they don't
my my arms almost never move except for
these very small degrees so if my hand
was on the Y Line here this is the
amount of movement that that hand is
only allowed because it never crosses
the wo line it never crosses to the
other side
okay if I so so my movement is if the
arm movement maximum I can't go outside
the shoulder line and I can only go to
the wui line then that's all the
movement that I'm allowed on that if I
needed whatever I was holding on here to
Traverse the mat more that's where you
have to move your body but my arm never
goes past that it's very small movements
very small movements
okay and then we also know that the arms
don't lead those
movements the qua leads that movement so
when when I want my hand to go from here
to that that small movement what do you
guys say that
is how many
inches five six four four to six four to
six okay we'll take
it I I move the
quaw and that's what makes that four to
six my hand doesn't do it the quaw
pushes the elbow into the the technique
I wanted to come back home the qua is
moving the elbow not my ball and socket
joint here okay and then we also know
from previous videos that the
qua knee and foot have to uh stay in
alignment which is why you can't do
these stances in mod in Moder keto
they're not functioning correctly which
is why there's no qua in modern iino
okay because they're going to turn and
do these weird things it's like well I
don't have knee and foot alignment with
the qua okay so let's keep all that in
mind
now and we
start we still have my beginning and
ending and we still have the katata D
elbow
angle and I have to uh allow for the
wrist and elbow to move so don't go here
the wrist and elbow do not rotate around
each other they do rotate around each
other so I want to show you something
I'm just going to move I'm going to keep
the wrist and elbow angle and I'm just
going to move it from my right the Y
line to
the uh wui
line give him some rail to hold
okay you can see what
[Music]
happens now watch the watch the other
one where the wrist and elbow rotate
around each
other so we'll do it I'll do it faster
now so you can
see comes into me I'm on the other one
he's going to rotate around you as long
as these
do so
you're some of the complication that you
might be having is you're violating what
is actually an inward spiral and outward
spiral so you can see
tayor we just going to go
here and he will come back into me give
him some balance so he doesn't fall okay
he comes towards me how you see because
the elbow comes towards
me you do watch the where the elbow goes
the elbow's going away from me so he
goes around me okay so if you're trying
to bring him towards
you you're going to close off
the yin space that you need on the
entring he's coming at
you you're going to think that if you
bring it here you would get un over it
and you would feel your power but you
end up doing this
instead even if you go quicker he's very
heavy right there he's very heavy cuz
he's not already falling and I'm not
entering in true y space okay so you
have to
remember that they have to rotate around
each other not stay in the line in the
same spiraling relationship which is no
spiraling relationship okay then he will
go around me not into me if he doesn't
go into me I can enter into y space
because as he's going around me it's
opening not closing okay and this hand
this hand helps all that so again if you
just bring your arm and you watch my
elbow it's coming closer to me he comes
towards me but if I make my elbow go in
and my wrist goes out my elbow does not
come towards me he goes around me I'm
not closing off the yin space okay so
I'm not
going like this which is the fedorite
iido right right so they go like they're
swabbing the Pirates
at and then they bring them in we don't
have this Movement we don't have that
movement okay all right
so
then the other thing is when my elbow
does that when my elbow goes around the
wrist as the wrist of the elbow hand is
coming towards the wui line and this one
is coming to the Y
Line it is my qua that does that not not
my
arms so I don't want to
enter and then do
waste as you see here he's too far
around which is going to happen and it
doesn't actually show up in the
technique because that opening is going
to be gone by the time you do a two-step
Tak down okay it it's not un it's not
unlike we're here and I inter and then I
do my waist that's not what we do okay
the
qua the qua is going to enter into the
rotation and all I need is 4 in of
rotation
not that other thing okay because as you
saw on that one my hand came past the
wuji line so I was over here and now how
much distance is that what do you say 2
feet you see that as opposed to my 4 in
okay
so as you're as you're entering you're
turning you're turning as you're
entering and as you're turning as you're
entering he's getting lighter not
heavier and the opening is remaining
open not closed okay so watch how you've
already entered and then you want to
turn that's not
it or of course worse you don't turn at
all you bring your arms in it's going to
close it like we said okay as as you're
entering you're turning turning
so if you
watch watch my
foot I think that's probably the biggest
indicator for someone to see cuz you
can't really see my clock
the foot
enters and it's
turning so when it when it hits it's
going to stop the qua
stops okay so I'm here and it's
turning boom
my foot doesn't end in this angle nor in
this angle
different move as a un
what this
does on the back side is my
Koshi goes back and attacks the center
okay so if I don't turn you'll push him
away you don't load the
kushion if you've
entered then
turn it's like barely loaded and you
over
rotate but if you do this boom
he's up here up here I don't know get
different
angles here
[Music]
okay let's try so by re uh reminding you
of all these um biomechanical
alignments what we're trying to get away
from is twisting you don't want to twist
there's no we don't twist okay um we
don't use the waist we don't
twist uh you don't use the waist because
when you twist the waist uh you're going
to um choke or compress like a balloon
animal maker would so you want to you
turn the middle of the balloon you you
you're doing that to your tonden and the
tonden goes goes out you just kill it
okay uh so we don't want to twist um for
energetic alchemical reasons obviously
than spiritual reasons but mechanically
it's just not powerful okay physically
it's not powerful so we don't want to
twist okay and if you align all these
things like I said you won't twist and
if you don't twist he moves all at
once he moves as I move as opposed to he
staying there or I moved or whatever so
so sometimes you can twist by having
your bottom half move first and then the
arms and you can do obviously the
reverse okay so the arms moved and then
the body moves last all right we don't
want either of those things okay so
we're going to put some on film that's
it's not easy and I think the reason
with my my take you guys bring some
awareness to this the reason it's not
easy is because you have to be able to
ground on one
foot because you have to be moving okay
and usually you're twisting because you
want to wait for the weight to get off
of you because we're
bracing and um you don't want to wait
entirely so you wait like half way
either top or bottom but now the
technique is gone okay so um when when
you're here like this you you're going
to you have to be on one foot okay and
uh you you can't be like
whoa and so and you also have to make
sure that he can go around you so that
you can turn the
quaw and all that is difficult it's not
so easy to do your grounding has to be
higher to be able to to do that okay cuz
there's a lot of weight all right try
it
some some things to
note is you don't want to you don't ever
enter and then bring him
around this way then you don't have you
don't have e you you lost it as your arm
past the wui line
you have to go to something else okay
you're going to have to do a hand change
and maybe come to here to to regain
control of it um back
up he does go around me but I'm not in
that relationship to his spine okay so
as I'm coming in he's here do you see
not here you see that difference okay
you keep loosening that thing
okay one day you're going to have to
choose if you're just going to be this
person that keeps protecting themselves
okay okay or you're going to be
vulnerable and start taking some risk of
Faith okay right all right um
so the other thing let's
rewind let me use
mine run out of
time okay uh careful so that's one
caveat uh don't turn them so far that
you're in this you don't you lost theot
now okay second
caveat is don't just bump their hip here
you're bumping their hip you want to
love the cushion third
caveat don't
rud so you're you're doing some weird
thing here and then you kind of Rudder
around
you're here like this
no if you pay
attention the arm did not come where it
needs to
come okay so don't Rudder as you're
doing that don't bump them don't do a
variation of UR okay and the thing to
note on all that is if you're doing
everything else that I said um that none
of that that will happen and you'll load
the Koshi okay so if you're not loading
the Koshi or let's do this if you're
over rotating into a UDA variant or
you're
ruing um or your hand did not come to
the wui line cuz you're bumping them
it's because you're violating some of
those other motion drills okay so film
your eles and then see did I do
this or did I do that or did I do that
or
this okay and you just keep going
through all that kind of stuff did my
foot go straight did I twist in any way
twist no I don't twist in order to do
all these mistakes you had to violate
some of those other
biomechanical um parameters
okay